FLYNN KNEW HE WAS LYING TO THEM.
TO AN END TO FOLLOW THAT.
THERE ARE SIGNALS TONIGHT THAT
ONE OFFICIAL CHARACTERIZED AS A
MEDIA THREAT AGAINST AMERICAN
INTERESTS ON THE MIDDLE EAST HAS
DIMINISHED AS OF NOW.
LAWMAKERS RECEIVED BRIEFINGS
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO, PATRICK SHANAHAN, AND
JOE DUNFORD.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER GRIFFIN
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM THE
PENTAGON.
>> IT WAS NOT VERY ENLIGHTENING.
>> DEMOCRATS WHO DEMANDED
SECURITY BRIEFINGS WITH THE ROD
REMAINED SKEPTICAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD A PLAN TO
AVOID A WAR.
>> WE KNOW THEY ARE BAD.
WHAT IS THE POLICY GOING FORWAR
FORWARD?
>> A WAR WITH IRAN WOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE DISASTER AND I HOPE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TELL THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE WILL NOT
GO TO WAR.
>> THIS IS BLIND ESCALATION WITH
THE HOPE THAT THE IRRADIANCE
WILL COME TO THE TABLE.
>> LAWMAKERS HAD A DIFFERENT
REACTION.
>> IT WAS A VERY GOOD PRETHING,
THEY CAN EXPLAIN HOW IT WAS
DIFFERENT THAN IN THE PAST AND
HOW THE ATTACK ON THE SHIPS ON
THE PIPELINE WAS COORDINATED AND
DIRECTED BY THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> THERE IS NO INTENTION TO GO
TO WORK IN THE REGION.
THIS IS A DETERRENT OPERATION TO
STOP IRAN'S ESCALATION.
>> PATRICK SHANAHAN DEFENDED THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT LED THE
PENTAGON TO DEPLOY THE U.S.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN HAD TO SCHEDULE.
>> THAT INTELLIGENCE IS BORNE
OUT ATTACKS AND I WOULD SAY IT'S
ALSO DETERMINED ATTACKS.
WE HAVE DETERRED ATTACKS BASED
ON OUR POSTURING OF ASSETS.
WE HAVE DETERRED ATTACKS AGAINST
AMERICAN FORCES.
>> WE WALKED THROUGH OUR EFFORTS
AND OUR OBJECTIVE WHICH HAS BEEN
TO DETER IRAQ.
>> THEY ROLLED OUT NEGOTIATED
WITH A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WARNING
THIRD PARTIES MAY TRY TO PULL
IRAN AND THE U.S. INTO A DIRECT
CONFRONTATION.
>> WE BELIEVE THE UNITED STATES
IS PLAYING A DANGEROUS GAME.
>> THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEF HAS CANCELED A TRIP TO
NATO DUE TO "UNFORESEEN